i i don't know if you've gotten a chance
to see this i'd love to also mention
this um
twitter feud
between two other interesting people
which is uh brett weinstein and sam
harris or sam harris and others in
general
and uh it kind of breaks my heart
that these two people i listen to that
are very thoughtful about a bunch of
issues let's let's put covet aside
because people are very emotional about
this topic
i mean i think they're deeply
thoughtful and intelligent
whether you agree with them or not and i
always learn something from their
conversations and they are legitimately
or have been for long time friends
and it's a little bit heartbreaking to
me
to see that they basically don't talk in
private anymore
and there's occasional jabs on twitter
and um
i hope that changes i hope that changes
in general for kovid that kovy brought
out the the i would say
the most emotional sides of people the
worst in people
and
i think there hasn't been enough
love and empathy and compassion and to
see
two people from whom i've learned a lot
whether it's eric weinstein brett
weinstein sam harris you can criticize
them as much as you want their ideas as
much as you want but if if you're not
sufficiently open-minded
to admit that you have a lot to learn
from their conversations
i think you're not
being honest and so i i do hope they
have those conversations and i hope we
can kind of i think there's a lot of
repairing to be done post covid yeah
of of relationships
of conversations and i think
empathy and love can help a lot there
and this is also just a
i i talked to
uh sam privately but this is also a
public call out to
to put a little bit more
uh
love in the world um
yeah and and for these difficult
conversations
to
to happen
because um
brett weinstein
could be very wrong
about a bunch of topics here around
covid
but he could also be right and the only
way to find out is to have those
conversations
because there's a lot of people
listening to both sam harris and brett
weinstein
and uh if you go into these uh silos
where uh you just keep telling each
other
the
uh
that you are the possessors of truth and
nobody else is the possessor of truth
what starts happening is
you both lose
track or the capability of arriving at
the truth because nobody's in the
possession of the truth
so anyway it's just the call out that we
should have a little bit more
conversation a little bit more like
totally agree and and both of those guys
are guys who i uh who i respect and as
you know uh brett and again as i
mentioned they're just a handful of us
um who were the early people raising
questions about about the origin that's
right he was pandemic right he was there
also talking yeah so people have heard
him speak quite a bit about antiviral
drugs and all that kind of stuff but he
was also
raising concerns about lab leak early on
yeah exactly and so but i completely
agree with you
that
we don't have to agree with everybody
but it's great to have healthy
conversations that's how how we grow and
absolutely
um we live in in a world where we're
kind of if we're not careful pushed into
these little information pockets and
certainly on social media i have
different parts of my of my life one is
focusing on issues of um of covert
origins and then i have genetics and
biotechnology and then i have which
maybe we'll talk about later one shared
world which is about how do we build a
safer
future and when i say critical things
like
the chinese government we have to demand
a full investigation into pandemic
origins this is an outrage then it's
really popular when i say let's build a
better future for everyone in peace and
love it's like wow three people liked it
and one was one was my mother and so i
just feel like
we need to build we used to have that
connectivity just built in
um because we had these town squares and
and you couldn't get away from them now
we can get away from them so the i so
engaging with people who have a
different background is really essential
i mean i'm on
fox news
sometimes you know three four times a
week and i wouldn't in my normal life
i'm not watching that much of
fox news or even television more more
generally
but i just feel like if i just speak to
people who are
very similar to me it'll be comfortable
um but what what have i contributed so i
think we really have to have those those
kinds of of conversations and and
recognize that at the end of the day
most people
want to be happy they want to live in a
better world they maybe have different
paths to get there
but if we just break into
camps that don't even connect with each
other that's a much more dangerous world
you